han pasado casi 40 años desde que el vih
o virus de la inmunodeficiencia humana
comenzó a expandirse por el mundo hoy
afecta a más de 48 millones de personas
los primeros pacientes se exponían a una
discriminación extrema y había una
sensación de misterio una sensación de
miedo un claro prejuicio un aumento una
actitud de exclusión definida
generalidad artur fue etiquetado
inicialmente como el cáncer gay por ser
frecuente en esa comunidad sólo años más
tarde se supo que éste afectaba a
hombres mujeres y niños por igual los
investigadores franceses françoise barré
sinoussi y luc montagnier lo
identificaron en 1983 el virus que se
propaga por fluidos corporales se
expandió rápidamente por todo el mundo
su combate ha sido lento en 1986 se
lanzó el primer fármaco con eficacia
demostrada para contener el vih y aunque
no fue muy contundente dio lugar al
desarrollo de muchos otros medicamentos
contra la enfermedad
este año el fármaco cavo tegra beer ha
aprobado una mejor eficacia en prevenir
el virus que otros
pero la búsqueda de una vacuna aún está
en curso sin embargo la lucha contra el
sida se ha vuelto más compleja conocida
advierte que el brote mundial de
coronavirus ha interrumpido los
suministros de medicamentos contra esta
enfermedad en todo el mundo así fue tu
mans durante dos meses estuve usando
solo un medicamento se suponía que debía
usar dos y si no uso los dos es un gran
riesgo y puedo enfermarme en picor y el
impacto de la pandemia podría causar
indirectamente entre 69 mil y 148 mil
muertes adicionales este año con un
impacto especial en áfrica con 24
millones de pacientes